bonsoir alex rivière merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france petit
report 12 17 ans avancé olivier verrons
ce soir c'est un soulagement du côté des
parents d'élèves dans la mesure où on a
été en retard se focalise sur tout
disons que cela juste et un calendrier
un peu plus logique ça peut paraître
normal mais les non s'interroge beaucoup
sur cet apartheid social qui va être mis
en place et sanitaire puisque on sait
que les les familles qui ne voient là
qu'ils ne vont pas vers les lieux de
culture ou qui ne peuvent pas financer
des des loisirs qui par des tractions ce
genre de choses humala la nécessité va
être beaucoup moins beaucoup moins
omniprésente et pour l'instant on n'a
pas de détails concernant l'école enfin
c'est nous on a quand même passé notre
année à chercher des médecins scolaires
des infirmières donc on se demande bien
comment est ce que le système scolaire
va s'adapter à cette à cette nouvelle
réalité de peut-être vacciner les élèves
en milieu scolaire sachant qu'en plus il
va faire l'autorisation des parents et
que vu le peu de pédagogie et de débats
citoyens qu'il ya pu avoir sur ce sujet
parce que c'est pas ça s'est pas produit
à l'assemblée ça s'est produit au sénat
je ne sais pas de cours ni parle si ce
n'est pas de parler de cela et nous en
tout cas les parents ce qu'on 9 sur le
terrain où tout au long de l'année c'est
qu'on a fait assez peu qu'a finalement
du bien-être des élèves parce que
effectivement l'ex trivières vous faites
référence au fait que le président
mettront certainement annoncé une
campagne de vaccination dans les
collèges et les lycées c'est vrai que ça
peut peut-être être surprenant est ce
qu'on doit craindre
peut-être une opposition de la part des
parents selon vous parce qu'on imagine
que vacciner un enfant de 12 ans n'est
pas exactement pareil que de vacciner un
adulte évidemment que les parents vont
s'inquiéter et moi ce qui mine ce qui me
choque c'est qu'en france on a quand
même et ça choque tous les parents en
france on a quand même suffisamment de
forces intellectuelles pour vraiment
débattre sur ce sujet de façon
intéressante constructive et peut-être
convaincre ou pas les 25%
d'ailleurs ce chiffre intéressant
puisque c'était en seine saint denis
c'est le même pourcentage de parents qui
ne voulaient pas envoyer leurs enfants à
l'école
à la fin du premier confinement dur
mais en l'occurrence là c'est quelque
chose d'arbitraire enfin nous on a du
mal à comprendre comment est ce que le
président se situe là dessus sur sur un
débat éclairé d'experts vraiment le
conseil scientifique c'est une émanation
spécifique à cette pandémie
on a plein de choses en france qui
peuvent nous aider l'académie de
médecine la sucette pédiatrie des gens
comme agnès goffart comme patrick berche
fin des gens qui sont hyper calé sur ces
sujets là et qui pourrait être être
force de proposition et au lieu de ça
non et nous nos plus grosses angoisses
c'est que cette quatrième vague va de
nouveau plonger les enfants les élèves
dans une dans un chaos scolaire ce sera
la troisième année consécutive et nous
ne sommes pas prêts à affronter cette
quatrième vague ou d'un point de vue
massification de d'un suivi scolaire à
distance pour tous les élèves de france
justement les fédérations de parents
d'élèves est ce que vous allez demandez
peut-être davantage de concertation de
deux débats avant l'organisation de ces
campagnes de vaccination parce que les
parents peuvent avoir des craintes
légitimes que tout simplement voilà du
jour au lendemain ces campagnes soit
organisée et que du jour au lendemain
peut-être les élèves non vaccinées soit
exclu de certaines activités peut-être
péri scolaires ou des cours de sport
sait-on jamais mais effectivement
falloir que le ministre ait et le
président précise ce genre de choses
parce que oui les parents sont là pour
l'instant
y'aura vacances ou pas faut se rappeler
quand même que c'est un enfant sur trois
qui part en vacances en france donc
c'est pas non plus une majorité est là
la surprise de la rentrée des risques
d'être à voir sans se douche froide oui
bien sûr surtout si on peut pas
accueillir les enfants à l'école
auriez-vous souhaité que ce cette
décision soit prise à l'issue peut-être
d'un débat citoyen c'était peut-être ont
la meilleure solution pour apaiser les
craintes dans la mesure où en plus on le
président macron à chercher
à voir comment dire une coopération
européenne sur tout ce qui est gestion
de la vaccination
moi je m'étonne qu'on ne soit pas
capable de faire appel faire appel à la
fois encore intermédiaire à la fois les
élus de la république à l'assemblée et
au sénat ce passé c'est quand même
préoccupant de se dire que le débat des
présidentielles prend pas sur tout y
compris sur sur un sujet aussi important
la rentrée comment vous l'abordez
justement avec ce spectre du variant
delta on peut se dire ça y est
maintenant on est habitués on va pouvoir
réagir on sait pour autant la confusion
au sein des établissements et les choses
pèse sur les directeurs d'établissements
notamment la pandémie n'a jamais quitté
l'école depuis depuis mars 2020 il faut
se rappeler quand même ce la fin boyer
ou le confinement tout ça mais dès la
reprise la pandémie n'a jamais quitté
l'école et c'est ce qui d'ailleurs forcé
toutes les équipes scolaires y les
élèves aussi à gérer des situations au
tout au long de l'année qu'il fait
qu'ils n'étaient absolument pas sereine
au regard des apprentissages nous on a
demandé des choses très précises qui
pourrait jeter les lycées français de
l'étranger ils ont tous fait des groupes
restreints dans leur classe pourquoi
est-ce que ce pont pourquoi est ce qu'on
arrive à faire sur les lycées français à
l'étranger
on n'arrive pas à le transposer en
france métropolitaine
je dire pourquoi est-ce que des classes
de 15,17 ça fonctionne mieux que des
classes aa 28 il ya tout un tas de
raisons mais on paraître pandémique
c'est super c'est super important
et cette distanciation des élèves et des
adultes qui en ont la charge
je vous rappelle quand même que ça fait
un an et demi qu'on nous le demandons
donc c'est enfin une année oui merci à
l'ifa rivière rappelle que vous êtes
porte parole de seine-saint-denis merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france oui allez si on arrive à être
inquiet on dit très inquiet sur les
écoles privées sous contrat qui ne qui
ne maîtrisent pas
les classeurs potentiel dans la mesure
où ils ont une offre cynique commercial
le dire nous on accueille les enfants en
plein jour et ça c'est extrêmement
dangereux et là on est très inquiet là
dessus au niveau de la gestion pour
avoir les pouvoirs publics merci de
votre écoute
merci à bout surtout alix à rivière
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france